hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 29th of July today and you are tuned
in gamespot news in these are things I
would like to spend a bunch of money I
don't have on a costume ps4 called the
gate station has been unveiled in an
auction for charity the colorful system
is being auctioned off to support the
Swedish foundation for lesbian gay
bisexual and queer rights and its bids
have already passed 2,500 bucks the
auction still has a little time left as
it doesn't close until the second of
august so if you want to trade a wad of
useless money for a nifty rainbow
PlayStation 4 you can still do that
Swedish games retailer web Halen have
said for many young people the world of
games will become a refuge to escape the
taunting or worse of real life on the
web Halen we are gamers in heart and
mind and akeem that as many as possible
have the opportunity to feel welcome and
enjoy the world's largest and fastest
growing interest video games next up the
destiny beta is done and dusted so if
you were thinking about cracking into it
you'll have to wait until sep tember
Bungie called the beta a tremendous
success and said that they've learned a
whole bunch about the game and what they
can implement to make it better while
community manager Eric Osborne wrote on
Twitter that he was quote gobsmacked by
the numbers we haven't actually heard
any specifics on what those numbers were
as yet Bungie also teased that this was
only the beginning by saying your next
adventure begins on sep tember night
when we launched destiny once we do that
we intend to keep it in orbit for a very
long time c star side last up it's been
a while since the game's personality
came out with something controversial to
say but doom created John Romero has
saved the day by saying that pc is
decimating console the dev told games
industry international that this is
because pc games are often less
expensive and that the pc platform is
more open than traditional consoles
Romero said that PCs are a continually
evolving platform while consoles get
stuck in long life cycles he cited the
examples of free-to-play and steam games
as cheap options and then continue to
stir the discussion pot by saying
freedom
has killed 800 triple-a studios he
described the PC shareware model of the
90s as the ultimate version of
free-to-play where they put out the
first episode of doom or Wolfenstein for
free and if people liked it they could
pay to play more Romero has also argued
that devs are getting better at
designing free to play gears and he
expects the model stigma to fame and as
your question of the day let me know
down in the comments if you reckon
gamers will come around to free-to-play
and if you think it's a good or a bad
thing those are all the things I wanted
to tell you about today as always be
sure to leave me your opinions and i
will see you same time tomorrow